podcast baby you already know shout out
to Stockton shout out to the 209 man and
be now in the [__] building
baby let's get to it
[Music]
hey
first and foremost don't get me Mr with
the rest of them I'm by the back I need
a stack before I have sex again I see
that snake [__] he acting weird and then
we asking the main type to talk typing
in addressing readdressing and re-axing
him hey ain't no back and forth that's
what we don't do my biggest problem is
telling people out there go to if it was
the other way around who can I go to I'm
the type to hide my problems I just put
it in these Pro Tools mainly business
hey Ferraris Lamborghinis exotic [__]
diamonds designing [__] we've been
dreaming 99 problems but a [__] ain't
never need them hey stop calling me yo
brother when I was broke ain't never
seen them hey y'all not running [__]
y'all looking like paraplegic so these
tattoos on my body got a meaning should
I be taking losses only show y'all my
achievements used to wake up mad as [__]
cause I ain't getting no toys on
Christmas tree that boy bands known for
leaving suckers twitching it was mean
squeeze hitting that row slaps in the
Civic leak just called just hit my
lineup sending chicken bro just Cottage
their body you see him change he need
like three of them caught that boy
sitting he got hit with a [__] who
ain't make it to the spittle better keep
your is to wrap my life I ain't talking
no riddles I got dogs inside that kennel
they pushing them issues write them in
they get you disrespecting it's coming
with missiles
they just come with missiles come on
keep going it's coming with me write
them in there get you what's coming hey
watch both sides when you cry some no
dang ones they can switch to hang around
with some young boys my dogs from you
pick food I'm too deep in that water got
my pole on my swimsuit this baby hey
watch somebody knows this [__] needs no
tissue Nelly yeah me suckers doing what
they [__] do four five in the photos
two two three seven six two is all type
of cars my driveway still slime around
some rentals that fan Shadow you get
popped ain't no monkey in the middle eh
I'm not a farmer but they calling me for
chicken ain't funny now I got it but you
don't so now I'm Different sold out
shows overseas I don't reply to dishes
[__] I'm not hot it's in the city plane
just landed now I'm in the trenches if I
was Smarter with my money probably touch
a million I just want a car with the
Stars just replace the ceiling hey just
replace the ceiling
man you already know new EP coming man
uh run it up on the 17th when it drops
that was hard brother appreciate you
coming up all day you already know
hey I know you just watched the new
freestyle guess what we're dropping them
every week sometimes more than once a
week Jesus we've been dropping a lot
lately uh shout out to LRG don't forget
go to L Dash R Dash g.com use the promo
code bootleg save 30 off in check out
you get this look at this jacket look at
that lining
it's LRG baby 30 off this bad boy go to
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg and save 30
off at checkout and check out another
freestyle next week